[موسيقى]
هذا المكان هو مدينة تسمى فم عيسى
وهي معروفة أيضًا باسم المدينة الصفراء
[موسيقى
] وتعرف باسم المدينة الصفراء لأن
المركز بأكمله يحتاج إلى
الأصفر
[موسيقى
] وهو معروف باسم مدينة
الثقافات الثلاث  لأنه هنا لديك أهداف
من حضارة المايا القديمة
والعمارة الاستعمارية ولديك مظهر
مايا الحديث الذي لا يزال يعيش هنا في
المدينة
[موسيقى
] الاسم يعني أن تفعل ذلك من
السماء
[موسيقى]
عندما بدأت في التوجيه لأول مرة
قيل لي  أنه تم طلاؤه باللون الأصفر
تكريماً لزيارة البابا يوحنا بولس
الثانية في عام 1993 ، لذلك
كررت هذا بأمانة شديدة لسنوات حتى قلت
هذا أمام مرشد سياحي آخر
قال لا ، لم يكن الأمر أصفر بالفعل ،
بدأت أسأل من
حولي وأتحدث إلى أشخاص مختلفين لا يبدو
أن أحدًا يعرف
[موسيقى]
مدينة المايا التي تقع تحت
المدينة الإسبانية تأسست على الأرجح في
القرون القليلة الأولى قبل المسيح
، تأسست المدينة الإسبانية في خمسينيات القرن الخامس عشر
لأنها كانت كذلك  مكانًا مهمًا
للحج لهذا ، قرر الكاثوليك المايا
أن هذا سيكون مكانًا جيدًا
حقًا لوضع إحدى الكنائس الأولى
في شبه جزيرة يوكاتان ، لذلك قاموا
ببناء الكنيسة وافتتحوا ديرًا
هنا كان مخصصًا لتحويل
شعوب المايا.  solecism Izumo هي
واحدة من pueblos المكسيك في المكسيك
مما يعني أنها واحدة من المدن الساحرة
وهذا برنامج
أنشأته الحكومة المكسيكية لتحديد الأماكن
التي تكون مثيرة للاهتمام بشكل خاص
بسبب الجمال بسبب
أهميتها الثقافية ، هناك
أماكن خاصة  زيارة تستحق المجيء لاستكشافها